growing up i loved reading the guinness
book of world records and over the years
they verified some incredible physical
feats which i'm about to react to huge
thanks to dropbox for sponsoring this
video stay tuned to learn how you can
get a free trial of dropbox
professional most knuckles cracked in 30
seconds
i think this is my morning routine
caught on camera dr mike's morning
routine i feel like i could beat this
one
oh crap in the in the hamstring crap of
the hamstring
[Music]
vocal cords are obviously what give you
the ability to speak and produce sound
the larynx is a muscle by being able to
control that muscle whether you're
stretching it out you shortening it you
actually change your ability to control
your pitch and just like any other
muscle this muscle can be trained that's
why we have vocal coaches see how low
you can get
was that low i heard nothing
it was totally silent exactly it was
that
low what do we got here
is this an age-related one
[Music]
wow
116 as of march is this person still
lives yes she is still alive wow so two
years older three years older basically
oh birthday's coming up so gonna be uh a
solid 119 in a few days happy early
birthday kane tanaka
you think she knows
yep there you go she goes i don't know
what this is my name is nicholas james
stoberl and i have the longest tongue in
recorded history wow i think one of the
most useful things that my tongue offers
is actually not having to use a napkin
let's be popular with his partners
i use my tongue actually uh to create
you could call it art i sort of like to
paint on canvas using acrylic
everyone's got their thing he paints
with his tongue that's very long that's
the longest tongue in the world i'm sure
other people would be doing other things
with that tongue but maybe it wasn't
safe for guinness world records to
investigate further
what the longest time in an abdominal
plank position okay here we're talking
isometric contraction we're literally
not shortening not lengthening the
fibers but keeping them tight and
engaged the entire time before you keep
watching what's your prediction for the
longest plank i'm gonna say something
wild five hours
in february 2020 george hood playing for
nostalgia eight hours 15 minutes do he
have a catheter in place no way they put
a catheter in so he can pee
enter daniel scaley
three hours in and he's keeping good
form part of like the thing of keeping a
plank is having really strong shoulders
in addition to a strong core and the
core is not just your abdominal muscle
it's your obliques it's your posterior
erectile spine a muscles
five hours
six hours seven hour mark came my body
started to turn on me a little bit i
can't even do anything for seven hours
straight without taking a break and my
guy's planking i started to actually
vomit on myself he vomited
while doing it look at this guy he
didn't even need a catheter he vomited
while doing it
coming out of it it's got to be brutal
too stop stop the video we we need to
give him a group round of applause that
like is so hard my training will make 90
seconds mike i'm like 90 come on 60 75.
this guy nine plus hours i have the
biggest mouth in the world largest gape
i've never heard it referred to as a
gate well that is that is an open mouth
how many mcdonald cheeseburgers can
isaac fit his mouth do i want to know
the answer to that question he's wearing
a patriots shirt i wonder if he has some
lac city in his tmj area or is just
anatomically this is a normal variation
i am the guinness world record holder
for the most can stuck to a human head
what the most drink hands placed on the
head using air suction i'm fascinating
if a patient came to me and said can
stick to my head i would be at a loss i
wouldn't know should i refer should i
write a case report up like this is very
unique i went to a doctor i walked in
with a can of peanuts and i'm stuck to
the side of my head and goes how do you
do that i go that's what i'm here for i
want to find out how i do it so he did a
couple of things and
that's when he told me he thinks my skin
pores
suck in oxygen and makes things stick to
me and that i'm literally like one of
four in the world that he knows of what
that is the coolest thing i wonder if
there's any medical negatives from this
full can of uh peanuts i just
hold on is it this got to be a prank
this is real what's the condition his
body temperature is 100 degrees
fahrenheit which causes skin pores to
act like suction cups keaton's wounds
heal faster he gets sick less and ages
slower than most sticky skin syndrome
back to the records in just a second but
first i want to thank dropbox for
sponsoring this part of the video my
team and i use dropbox when making our
videos because it's a reliable storage
solution that doesn't share our private
information our footage can't be lost or
destroyed and it's easily accessible
anytime anywhere dropbox professional
allows for external collaboration and
creative workflow we are regularly
storing and sharing large files like the
raw clips to this video that you're
watching right now and with dropbox
secure backup choosing them was a
no-brainer they even allow access to
files on multiple devices like how i'm
viewing these world record videos on
dropbox on my computer while sam follows
along with me through dropbox on his
phone it allows us to focus on
productivity without the clutter and
distraction of searching for content and
switching between too many things their
premium features and advanced sharing
tools streamline our entire workflow and
help us impress our partners when we
send them videos to review it's
essential to our entire production
process visit dropbox.com dr mike and
start a free trial of dropbox
professional now huge thanks to dropbox
again for sponsoring this part of the
video let's get back to the world
records
longest duration restraining four
motorcycles
no
this looks like a medieval torture
device
just imagine if this goes wrong and the
gentleman loses an arm don't do this at
home don't do this at work there is no
reason to do this can you imagine that
guy walking into a bar hey babe what's
up you know what i did last night i tied
up motorcycles to all of my limbs and
let them pull me apart and they couldn't
do it for 24 seconds how you doing
i feel like you could literally make
anything a record if you really want it
to be a record yo tell them i did this
eight times
no one knows what's the record look at
that
no i just set the record
most consecutive muscle yo
oh man muscle ups are so hard tricep lat
biceps strength forearm strength grip so
much is happening in good form too
excellent form
wow
26 is the record i feel like i've seen
some dudes in central park that could
probably beat this there's also some
gymnasts that i feel like that might be
able to beat that
longest duration full body contact with
ice that already sounds painful the real
danger with ice when it is making full
body contact is that it can actually
burn your skin that's why when i tell
you put some ice on your injured
shoulder or knee i always say put
something in between because i don't
want you to burn your skin you could
literally develop frostbite and this
person's just chilling he beat the
previous record of two hours 35 minutes
how much further can he go his heart
rate's probably so low
the reason you see him shivering there
is he's trying to warm up about three
hours 28 seconds i love that it's
sponsored by these brands like who's
doing that
whoa
his ear temperature is 33 that's really
low so he's hypothermic i'm kathy young
and i am currently in the guinness book
for the smallest waste i'm a living
person
this is very not recommended and
unhealthy a few things happen when you
wear a waist trainer like that one you
start actually weakening your core
muscles because you're not allowing them
to expand properly and function properly
second you're also cramming your your
intestines from properly performing
peristalsis which is that movement of
food throughout your body then you're
also affecting your breathing because in
order to breathe your ribs need to
expand properly and your diaphragm needs
to lower that's why we talk about belly
breathing so when you shallow breathe
like that you actually lose a part of
your lungs through a condition known as
atelectasis but also it's short-lived if
you stop wearing the corsets it'll
return back to normal and thank god for
that the human body wants to return back
to normal sultan cosine eight foot one
246
and a half centimeters confirmed as the
guinness world records world's tallest
man wow he has a pituitary tumor
secreting a hormone called growth
hormone the pituitary gland is sometimes
known as like the master gland because
it secretes some of the most important
hormones that actually end up regulating
sometimes other hormones sometimes you
can have a tumor grow in the pituitary
gland which is actually not cancerous
but it is one that produces more of a
certain hormone also melanocytes which
secrete melanin the cells uh that give
your skin pigment actually are
controlled by melanocyte stimulating
hormone which is also found in your
pituitary gland how tall are you thank
you
24 inches two feet how was it to hear in
american horror story
[Music]
oh that's cool
that's a great way to turn something
unique that's happened to you into a
strength into an asset a good example of
post-traumatic growth there
okay what are we about to do
most consecutive stairs climbed while
balancing a person on the head who set
this record in the first place wow
i have trouble doing a handstand these
guys are headstanding up steps well
deserved and look at the beautiful
location this should be a double award
most beautiful backdrop for consecutive
stairs climb with the person on the head
i wonder how long they practiced oh my
god can you imagine if they mess up
you fall down all those steps worst fear
what is this a contest for albert
einstein look-alikes
oh are these like hyper smellers it's
like hyperasmia or something
yeah
it's really true though there are some
people who are considered super smellers
in fact we did a whole special episode
tailored to an individual who was a
super smeller and can actually smell
parkinson's on certain patients
including her own husband remember the
sense of smell is a chemical receptor
it's when a chemical binds to the
olfactory epithelium within your nose
and it starts sending nerve signals to
your brain in order for you to
understand what that chemical is
the longest nose on a living person
belongs to this person just because his
nose is long doesn't mean that's why he
has such a great sense of smell remember
this is a neurological phenomenon that's
happening but i will say you can have
disturbances in your anatomy the
olfactory cleft can be bigger or smaller
and some people are blocked off in
others where it could decide whether or
not you have a strong sense of smell the
olfactory region in dogs in comparison
to humans is so much better like 40 000
times better
click here for a doctor day in the
lifelong i literally go see a
dermatologist to get my eye injected
that's right i know it doesn't make a
lot of sense so click here to watch it
cool day day in the life of a doctor
click here as always stay happy and
healthy but most importantly click here